y
[Música]
el presidente decidirá en cambio del
país y ya aterrizó en las islas maldivas
gotabhaya rajapakse busca el exilio de
en medio de las protestas
antigubernamentales que exigen su
renuncia y que lo responsabilizan de la
peor crisis económica en años
ucrania intentar recuperar la región de
gerzón mientras que miles de familias
lloran a los seres queridos que han
perdido por la arena en esta emisión les
traemos una historia de lo que recuerdan
los sobrevivientes
y haití podría enfrentar una crisis
alimentaria a causa del incremento de la
violencia el programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu denunció que no ha
podido entregar suministros por el fuego
cruzado y las cosechas no se transportan
por la interrupción en las carreteras
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión aquí en
france24 yo soy marie claire a calle y
es un placer volver a estar con ustedes
comenzamos con noticias del sudeste
asiático el presidente de sri lanka
gotabaya rajapaksa abandonó el país en
un avión militar y fuentes oficiales
confirmaron que está en la vecina islas
maldivas esto ocurre luego de que hoy
funcionarios de inmigración impidieron
que su hermano y ex ministro de finanzas
basil rajapaksa saliera del país
entretanto dos cientos de personas
siguen acudiendo al palacio presidencial
después de que los manifestantes
asaltaron la residencia del sábado
la victoria parece estar a la vista para
los manifestantes decir blanca pero dos
días después de haber forzado al
presidente a anunciar su dimisión siguen
en las calles y ocupando el palacio
presidencial la calma ha vuelto a
colombo pero hasta qué gotabaya
rajapaksa no se aparte como prometió el
miércoles la gente no se mueve
la gente no abandonará la residencia del
presidente ni la del primer ministro
hasta que los líderes limiten
oficialmente si no se van el miércoles
13 el pueblo a saltar a cualquier
edificio en el que se escondan
el martes los funcionarios de
inmigración de cine lanka dijeron que
habían impedido que el hermano de raya
pax a basil ex ministro de finanzas
saliera del país un día antes se informó
que el presidente fue escoltado hasta
una base aérea lo que suscitó las
especulaciones de que también intentaría
exiliarse ambos rajapaksa tienen la
nacionalidad estadounidense el
presidente ha prometido dimitir para dar
paso a un gobierno de unidad se espera
que la principal oposición designe al
líder saljic premadasa hijo del
presidente asesinado rana cine premadasa
como su candidato a la jefatura del
estado
el mandato popular del presidente del
primer ministro y del gobierno ha
terminado única tudela
porque se han unido y han destruido
nuestra hermosa patria nosotros en la
oposición
estamos dispuestos a liderar a
estabilizar el país a reconstruir la
economía del país
el parlamento de sri lanka elegirá un
nuevo presidente el 20 de julio
ahora hablemos de la guerra en ucrania
las fuerzas de kiev contra atacan en el
sur del país para intentar retomar la
región de gerzón controlada por rusia el
ejército ucraniano atacó con misiles de
largo alcance y afirmó que mató a 52
personas mientras que las autoridades
rusas que gobiernan la región hablan de
siete fallecidos esto después de que
eeuu le diera a ucrania sistemas
avanzados de artillería móvil llamados
him arts por otra parte la
autoproclamada república de donges que
inauguró una embajada en rusia todo
mientras miles de familias lloran a sus
seres queridos muertos nuestros enviados
especiales catalina gómez ángel y oriol
andrés gallardo visitaron el oeste
ucraniano donde la guerra está presente
en la memoria
las vallas que hacen homenaje a los
soldados que combaten en el frente de
batalla parecen ser el único rastro de
la guerra que se libra cientos de
kilómetros de distancia de poblaciones
ubicadas en el oeste de ucrania
pero esta familia recuerda que el dolor
se extiende por todo el país
volodomir es uno de los tantos jóvenes
que se alistaron el mismo día que rusia
comenzó la invasión el 24 de febrero
irene su madre cuenta que algunos de los
amigos lo intentaron convencer de que se
esperara unos días y se uniera
posteriormente a las fuerzas especiales
pero él quiso integrarse de inmediato
murió a comienzos de marzo cuando
realizaban una operación en el norte de
ucrania tenía 26 años desde entonces su
familia incluida su prometida olga
intentan aprender a vivir con sus
recuerdos con un año con cada funeral le
perdemos más esperanza
tengo mucho pensar que hombres tan
jóvenes se estén muriendo
el gobierno de ucrania no publica las
cifras de los soldados muertos pero el
presidente volodomir selenski dijo que
en la batalla por la región del donbass
en el este del país más de 200
combatientes morían diariamente
la artista iván también recuerda su hijo
artem que murió en el frente el 18 de
junio ha podido recuperar el libro de
zénica que lo había acompañado hasta la
guerra hits looking to to harmony
él buscaba la armonía armonizar sus
sentimientos no es fácil matar gente
cuando se tiene 27 años
antes eran la pasión de artem era la
historia pero también el paracaidismo se
encontraba en un viaje de aventura
cuando comenzó la guerra y no dudó en
regresar y enlistarse como voluntarios
recibió un mensaje en el que me decían
que lo sentían mucho que algo terrible
había pasado pero yo no sabía quién
llamé de vuelta y le pregunté al hombre
quién es porque tengo dos hijos en la
guerra
su terapia seguir pintando para
exorcizar la tristeza de la pérdida y la
angustia no saber el estado de su otro
hijo pero cree que no es tiempo de
llorar sino de apoyarse entre todos los
ucranianos
otro de los efectos de la guerra se
siente en la economía ante el temor de
los inversionistas de que la crisis
energética en europa provoque una
recesión el euro ha caído como nunca en
los últimos 20 años aunque hoy se
recuperó una centésimas vale casi lo
mismo que el dólar a pesar de la
devaluación de esa moneda algunos países
como croacia le siguen apostando al
bloque de los 27 precisamente hoy fue
aceptado como el nuevo miembro de la
zona euro los croatas dirán adiós a las
cunas y darán la bienvenida al euro como
moneda oficial a partir del próximo
primero de enero
yo no inseguro unirse al euro traerá
beneficios económicos tangibles para
croacia hará que sea más fácil y
atractivo invertir en su país reducirá
las barreras para las empresas y
eliminará el costo del cambio de moneda
también ayudará a estabilizar las tasas
de interés lo que facilitará y hará más
barato para las personas y las empresas
pedir dinero prestado tiene además un
impacto positivo en el crecimiento
gracias a la plena integración en el
mercado único de la unión europea el
euro sigue siendo una moneda atractiva
la segunda más importante del mundo el
yen japonés pero debilitada frente al
dólar con el que está a menos de un
céntimo de alcanzar una paridad que no
tenía desde julio de 2012 la caída del
euro puede crear más problemas porque
mucha gente que tiene ahorros en euros
se van a ir al dólar para esta situación
eso es justamente por lo que estaba
explicando que la suba de las tasas de
interés y el miedo que existe en este
momento para los distintos
inversores de tener el dinero en europa
con todo este problema de guerra y
problema de
lo que es energía y pasarse a eeuu que
encontrar sus fallas sigue siendo más
seguro débil o no el euro es para los
croatas un símbolo de unión con el
bloque comunitario y una forma de seguir
los pasos de su vecina eslovenia también
ex república yugoslava que ya lo había
adoptado en 2007
el departamento de defensa de eeuu
confirmó la muerte de quien sería el
líder del grupo militante estado
islámico en siria de acuerdo con el
pentágono los militares estadounidenses
atacaron a maher al gal con un dron
mientras conducía una motocicleta cerca
de inditex en el norte de siria
washington afirma que él era el
responsable de desarrollar las redes del
estado islámico fuera de irak y de siria
en noticias de américa del presidente de
panamá laurentino cortizo anunció que
congelará el precio del combustible a
partir del 15 de julio esta es una de
las concesiones que hacen para intentar
desactivar la huelga que ya lleva más de
una semana
juan pabló lucumí tiene los detalles
la huelga indefinida comenzó el 6 de
julio desde entonces maestros de todo
panamá han liderado multitudinarias
protestas a las que se han unido
trabajadores de construcción y miembros
de comunidades indígenas para exigirle
al gobierno que intervenga en los
precios del mercado en medio de una
elevada inflación exigimos aumento
general de salario reducción en los
precios de los medicamentos que se
acaben la monopolio de los medicamentos
que tienen ser senado al pueblo panameño
reducción en los precios de combustible
y disminución de los precios a la
canasta básica
ante las peticiones de los panameños y
luego de reunirse con sindicatos y
organizaciones sociales
el presidente de laurentino cortizo
anunció que congelará el precio del
galón del combustible para vehículos
particulares a partir del 15 de julio y
espera calmar el enojo de la población
mediante un decreto quiero anunciar que
he decidido ampliar la medida de
congelar el precio del galón de
combustible en 395 para los vehículos
particulares
a nivel nacional a partir del 15 de
julio
igualmente he convocado para mañana el
consejo de gabinete para aprobar un
decreto que congelará el precio de diez
productos adicionales de la canasta
básica
la protesta que se hace más fuerte con
el pasar de los días se ha transformado
en cierre de vías enfrentamientos con la
policía y hasta un paro educativo por
parte de los profesores
y podría enfrentar una crisis
alimentaria a causa del repunte de
violencia en los últimos tres meses el
programa mundial de alimentos de la onu
advirtió obstáculos para entregar su
ayuda alimentaria en la capital y el
organismo ha tenido que buscar
alternativas para hacer llegar la ayuda
por mar o por aire el informe es de
andrés granadillo
crisis alimentaria en puerto príncipe a
esto es lo que se enfrenta a la capital
de haití debido al incremento de la
violencia
esta violencia ha tenido un impacto en
los mercados en el comercio en los
medios de vida y aislado en la ciudad
del resto de haití las carreteras hacia
el sur se cortaron hace un año las
carreteras hacia el este se han cortado
hacia la república dominicana y las
carreteras hacia el norte
más de 50 personas han muerto en
enfrentamientos entre bandas desde el
viernes dijo un alcalde local en el
marco de un aumento de este tipo de
violencia en la nación caribeña grandes
zonas de puerto príncipe están
controladas por bandas los datos que
tenemos muestran que la situación en los
últimos 90 días ha empeorado y que
estamos en un punto de partida en el que
haití es un lugar muy vulnerable en el
que ya había un millón de personas en
esta ciudad con inseguridad alimentaria
aguda
las entregas de suministros de las
cosechas como los plátanos no pueden
llegar por carretera porque los camiones
corren el riesgo de ser tiroteados o
retenidos por él el programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu dijo que sus
entregas se han visto atrapadas en el
fuego cruzado por lo que ha creado un
servicio de transbordador vía marítima
que lleva la ayuda alimentaria importada
a puerto príncipe y a otras partes del
país también está utilizando vuelos
cortos para sus trabajadores sumado a
esto la inflación de los alimentos se
sitúa en torno al 52 por ciento la
crítica situación pone contra las
cuerdas en la frágil economía de uno de
los países más pobres de américa latina-
este miércoles terminará el hash que es
la peregrinación que hacen los
feligreses musulmanes a la meca en
arabia saudita y este año el viaje al
lugar sagrado se retomó por primera vez
desde que comenzó la pandemia del cob y
19 a propósito de esta conmemoración del
islam amal benotman nos cuenta la
importancia de la cava el edificio
alrededor del cual los peregrinos
realizan las siete vueltas en el rito de
circunvalación
visitarla al menos una vez en la vida es
un deber para todo musulmán la cava se
encuentra en el centro de la sagrada
mezquita de ahl haram en la ciudad de la
meca en arabia saudita durante la
peregrinación de lajas la cava desempeña
un papel fundamental
es considerada por los musulmanes como
la casa de dios en la tierra y la
tradición religiosa dada su fundación a
la época del profeta abraham tras entrar
en la gran mezquita de la meca los
fieles vestidos con el erian la
vestimenta blanca del peregrino
comienzan a caminar alrededor de la cama
recitando oraciones y girando en sentido
contrario a las agujas del reloj en un
curso opuesto al sol este ritual llamado
circunvalación es uno de los más
importantes de la peregrinación a la
meca en un marco de plata fijado a una
de las paredes de la cava se encuentra
la piedra negra entre las muchas
leyendas que rodean su origen una cuenta
que fue confiada a adam cuando salió del
paraíso y colocada en la cava por el
profeta mahoma durante la circunvalación
los peregrinos deben tocarla o almenos
levantar la mano hacia ella si no pueden
acercarse la tela de seda negra que
cubre la cava se llama quechua junto a
la puerta de cubierta de oro esta tela
es una de las piezas más preciosas del
edificio y su producción le cuesta a
arabia saudita unos 4 millones de euros
cada año en la parte superior del
bordado están tejidos con hilo de oro y
plata versos del corán y pasajes de la
bajada la profesión de fe musulmana la
peregrinación a la meca es la segunda
fuente de ingresos de arabia saudita
después del petróleo le dejó casi 12 mil
millones de dólares antes de la pandemia
lo que hace de la cava un símbolo
nacional más allá de su importancia
religiosa hasta aquí las noticias sigan
con nosotros
[Música]